look you know when someone dies you kind
of want to say something nice but I
can't say a [__] good word about Pat
Robertson what an awful man I wonder
what your take was gonna be on that one
I saw that I was like whoa how is Howard
gonna handle this you're not not gonna
find one good thing to say I'm
struggling man I'm trying to find
something good to say about this [__]
guy but boy oh boy was he just a
monstrous animal filled with hate and
filth I mean uh you know Baptist
Minister Conservative Christian
broadcaster Pat Robertson so he was 93
he died
and he presented himself as a man of God
but just said such hateful and insane
things on his TV show the 700 Club I
mean uh I mean crazy thing and you know
what look you have your beliefs but I
mean but also crazy [__] and uh
and he's one of those guys who made a
tremendous amount of money getting all
ladies to pledge 10 bucks a month at one
point to show his books and videos were
bringing in more than 300 million
dollars a year God bless
so here's a montage of some of the
[__] wacky [__] he used to say this
is mac and cheese is that a black thing
can demonic spirits attach themselves to
inanimate object the answers yet Satan
is real demonic power is real demon
possession is real you might get AIDS
and Kenya the people have Aids you got
to be careful I mean the towels can have
AIDS something happened a long time ago
in Haiti they got together and swore a
pact to the devil they said we will
serve you if you'll get us free from the
French I do think the Earth is is
hurtling toward some final conclusion we
all feel that all it did for him
yeah we all this is a we there's just
like the um like he'd he'd wait for a
real big tragedy night 9 11 and rub his
hands together and go feminism LED women
to witchcraft
and a lesbian equality and abortion and
then you know and then it would be like
oh that's why we were punished with 9
11. you know like equating a terrible
tragedy with his view of the world and
you know homosexuality destroys entire
civilizations and that's why you know
like come on man you don't know anything
you know Lee I'm a little sad to see
this great nation of ours go the way
that it is we're going to have a month
to celebrate gay lesbian transgender
pride month somebody's proud of being
transgendered
it's a tiny tiny tiny fraction of our
population one to two percent uh has
this particular orientation yet they
dominate dominate the news it's just
simply amazing but um
you know any country that openly
Embraces homosexuality through the
history of mankind has gone down into
ruin that's that's history that's the
historical record if there's whatever
Nation Embraces this so-called lifestyle
it ends up in the garbage heap of
History so let's watch what happens
every time a dick touches a butthole
someone gets struck by lightning in this
country
I don't know if you realize but that's
fact that's fact you can look it up that
lightning has hit everyone who's uh
uh put his penis inside a man's ass
I'm telling you you can sit there and
giggle with that little Charming giggle
but that's the truth all right Pat did
you see last week
on this show JD and Chris
had a smooch yes and and did you notice
that the Skies over Manhattan turned red
now
you go ahead and laugh all you want but
this is what God is doing to us our
skies were red because of this sinful
kiss between two men JD Harmeyer and
Chris Wiley
know that how do you know that because
it says it in the Bible
now that's a fact
and I tell you this and I hope they're
listening JD and Chris
you will have plenty of time to smooch
when you're burning in hell for all
eternity
and believe me these Canadian fires were
started by gay Canadian farmers
uh rubbing their penises together in the
woods as they do
I looked up at the sky over Manhattan
and do you know the smoke cloud was in
the shape of a giant penis
[Laughter]
it's huge
yeah I I guess I will miss doing my
impression of Pat yes yes there won't be
any more quotes like that